رغم انها معروفه بمجتمعاتها الفتيه الا ان
المنطقه العربيه تشهد تحولا ديمغرافيه
عميقا فبحسب تقارير الامم المتحده فان عدد
المسلمين في المنطقه العربيه سوف تتجاوز
اعداد الاطفال بحلول عام 2050 واليكم
المزيد من الارقام
قدرت نسبه الاشخاص الذين تتروحوا اعمارهم
بين الستين عاما وما فوق بحوالي سبعه في
المئه في المنطقه العربيه ويتوقع ان ترتفع
هذه النسبه الى 18% بحلول عام 2050 وبحسب
احصائيات نشرها مركز
يتجاوز فيها عدد كبار السن ال 10% من
اجمالي عدد سكان ولا يتوقع ان تصل الى
اكثر من ثلاثه عشر في المئه عام 2030
وبحلول عام 2030 سيلحق لبنان تونس يحتل
المركز الاول ضمن فئه الدول التي تتميز
بتقدم اقمار سكانها ايثه تشكل نسبه كبار
السن 15% اما في المغرب والجزائر وليبيا
ومصر فنسبه الاشخاص المسنين في هذه الدول
تصل الى 8% لعام 2030 سوف ترتفع نسبه الى
9.3
السعودي يتوقع ان تجد نسبه كبار العمر
فيها من ثلاثه في المئه الى اكثر من سبع
سنين عام 2030
ضمن فئه الدول التي تشهد دموعها باعمال
سكانها